yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
with another fallout 4 video now in this
video I'm going to be showing you guys
the quick and easy way to backup all of
your save files in Fallout 4 so that if
you're gonna do something that could be
risky in the game or using some form of
console commands or you just want to
have your saves be safe then I'm going
to show you guys how to do it really
quick it's really easy so let's get into
it so you're going to want to go into
windows explorer open that up and then
just go to your documents go to
documents in your documents should be my
games inside of my games should be
fallout 4 and inside of follow four
should be your saves and boom there are
all of your saves for fallout 4 there
should be all of your saved for Ella for
all your auto-saves all of your quick
saves and all of your manual saves you
see I have quite a few I need to delete
some of these but so this is just going
to be for backing them up so I'm not
going to delete them right now so what
you don't want to do and if these aren't
here they should be in your my games
folder and if that is not in your
Documents or for some reason you have a
documents page you're going to need to
find this folder and inside of this
folder should be the fallout 4 and then
the saves folder so just be wary of that
also steam should automatically back
your saves up to the cloud however this
is just a more concrete way of knowing
that your saves are safe in your own
computer so what you're going to want to
do is copy this saves file and just put
it wherever you have space put it where
you want to keep it where you'll know I
have a specific folder for follow for in
my larger hard drive so I'm going to
create a new folder here and I'm gonna
call it backup saves and inside of that
folder I am going to paste the previous
folder I copied which is the saves
folder it will copy my 376 items
obviously if you have less saves than
this which I would hope you guys do then
it will copy the less files it won't
take as long even though they didn't
take you long and then there you go this
is actually in a weird mode let's go
into details and
while all of your saves are backed up
and then you can name this whatever you
want so rename saves one since the first
time I back them up and there you go so
because I've enjoyed this quick little
tutorial tutorial it's not too big of a
deal but I hope you guys if you didn't
know how to backup your saves can now
back of your saves and be safe with your
fallout 4 content alright guys thank you
for watching if you want more fallout 4
videos check out my channels I do have a
lot of fallout 4 videos and yeah thanks
for watching peace out